قال وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمز كليفولي
ان مركز الجاذبيه الجيو السياسيه في
العالم يتجه النحو الجنوبي والشرق اضاف
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني ان الرئيس الروسي
لازم ربوتن جاهز لمسماه تدمير القوانين
التي تحمي الدول انه شن حربا تناقض قيما
نظام الدولي حسب تعبيره ليفر لي اكد ضروره
كسبي دعم المزيد من الدول بالدبلوماسيه
الصبوره والعلاقات ذات المنفعه المتبادله
من لندن معنا مراسله الجزيره مينا حربلو
مينا في اي سياق وردت تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني
رئيسي وزير التصريحات جاءت في سياق المكان
يعلن عنه وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
من يعني تحديد لملامح السياسه الخارجيه
البريطانيه في المستقبل حين قال بان حين
كان تحدث باستفاضه عن مزايا النظام الدولي
القائم على سياده القانون الدولي الذي قال
بانه جلب مزايا كثيره للعالم واا يعني كان
بفضله هذا الامن والاستقرار الذي تشهده
الدول لكنه قال بان الرئيس الروسي بغزوه
لاوكرانيا
وقال بانه مستعد من اجل يعني تدمير هذه
القوانين التي تحمي الدول وقال بانه يهدف
الى اعاده همم عقارب الساعه الى الوراء
حيث كانت الدول القويه تضغط على الدول
الاضعف لكن هو ايضا في هذا السياق حديث عن
سياده القانون اثار تساؤل من احد الصحفيين
الذين كان الذين كانوا متواجدين في اثناء
هذا المؤتمر همم خطاب الوزير الخارجيه
وساله عن يعني لو احترمتم القانون الدولي
لما غزوتهم العراق لكن الوزير رد عليه
بالقول انت تريدني بان اجيب على سؤال كنت
ساجيب عليه لو كنت انا وزير الخارجيه قبل
عقود ولكنه اضاف بان الحديد الان ليتمحور
حول كيفيه حمايه هذه الانجازات التي تحققت
بفضل هذا النظام العالمي وزير الخارجيه
اثناء توضيح ملامح هذه السياسه الخارجيه
قال بان بريطانيا ستتجه بالتجاه الدول
التي لم تكن تقليديه ولم تكن تربطها
علاقات وثيقه بالمملكه المتحده في امريكا
اللاتينيه وفي افريقيا وفي اسيا وقال بان
هذه الشركات ستكون مبنيه على اسس مدينه
بحيث انه تتطلب الصبر وتتطلب عقودا من اجل
تنفيذ هذه الخطوه والاجنده البريطانيه قال
بان هناك ستكون استثمارات الدوليه هاديه
لست مرات ستتمثل في ايضا استثمارات من قبل
الشراكه المجموع شراكه مجموعه السبعه
للاستثمار والبنيه التي تشكل مبادره كبديل
ومنافس للتمويل الصيني الصيني التي
تعتبرها لندن تحديا صعبا رغم ان وزير
الخارج
يتحدث عن الصين وقال بانها يمكن ان تكون
شريكا شريكا شريكا خير في مجالات من بينها
مجالات المناخ وهي تخفيف للهجه نوعا ما
همم رئيس الوزراء البريطاني همم ريشي سونا
كان قد تحدث عن الصين وقال بان السياسه
البريطانيه ستكون اكثر براغماتيه اذا
المنطق البريطانيا يقول بان هذه الدول في
الشرق في اسيا في امريكا اللاتينيه
افريقيا ستكون
كتير خلال على الساحه الدوليه خلال
الثلاثين عاما المقبله لذلك في بريطانيا
يجب ان تنافس من اجل الوصول اليها قبل ان
تصل اليها دول اخرى يمكن ان تعثر
يعني تشكل تحديا تاثير الغربي في هذه
الدول
باتت يعني التحدي الصعب لبريطانيا
اللاتيني ان الصين بزياره رئيسها الى
منطقه الشرق الاوسط ربما تثير بعد تساؤلات
لدى الحكومه البريطانيه وما اذا كانت ربما
قاسيه في تعاملها مع الشركات الصينيه التي
حرمتها من المشاركه شكرا